well hello you guys made it yeah
yeah
we made it we made it i didn't make it
but we made it we missed it we did it
okay on a scale of one to ten how good
of a mentor was will i am oh the best he
was 10. he's not a number nicolina
i don't care that was my answer the best
yeah that was so good yeah he was
awesome like he just had so much good
advice and like you were saying like he
just made you feel so safe and like it's
just like pals in a room are you guys
ready for carrie underwood
[Music]
i don't know if i was in the frame my
eye you were very much in the fridge oh
no you were sitting
she
was like she was my childhood hero like
you go on my youtube channel there's
like a hundred videos of me singing
carrie underwood covers from like
growing up i like i grew up on carrie
underwood i'm like
shocked that we get to i know
because i was just listening and i was
like can you say that one more time ryan
did i hear that one more time i was like
oh my god i just lost it it's crazy i
love it and it's only fitting we've got
two canadians
[Applause]
how are the canadians as fans and
supporters i mean they've been i mean i
live i still live in canada i miss leo
no i'm just kidding i love you no but i
live in canada like i um you know so the
support there i feel like is just
everyone's like oh my god a canadian oh
my god she lives in toronto oh my god
she's from a small town inside of
toronto i live there and it's just like
it's it's just so awesome it's magical
really because it's everything like i've
dreamed of growing up yeah and growing
up in canada you never think you're
going to be on american idol no so the
support is just
insane oh i love it what about you well
okay so
i don't i haven't i haven't lived in
canada for a while but like i've played
a lot of shows my dad's in like a
canadian rock band so i've like i have
quite a community of canadians that have
been rooting for me for a long time and
people are just so psyched about this
american idol thing and like canadians
go hard that's all i gotta say yeah
we don't play we're gonna play love to
hear it it was so nice to talk to you
guys and congratulations
thank you so go ladies
you